abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
Merhabalar
Şimdi sizlere bir soru soracağım ve
cevabını hepiniz için farklı olacak
başarı nedir
bu Sınavdan yüksek bir not almak mı iyi
maaşlı bir işte çalışıyor olmak mı yoksa
iyi bir aile sahibi olmak mı
o cevabın hepimiz için farklı olmasının
sebebi başarının bir beklenti durumunu
karşılıyor olması aslında aslında
başarının tanımını kendi içimizde koyan
bizleriz
çevremizin de bunu şekillendirilmesinde
ki Payı oldukça büyük özellikle Türkiye
gibi bir ülkede çocukluk yaşlardan
itibaren el Nadir felsefesinde büyütüldü
ümüz için kendi isteklerimizi unutup
başkalarını istekleri için hayatımızı
şekillendiriyoruz
Dolayısıyla başarı kriteri mizde bu
yönde etki etmekte
şu anda hepimizin hayal ettiği bir
başarı kriteri düşün hepinizin başarmak
istediği bir şeyin şu anda olduğunu
varsayalım kendinizi başarılı hisseder
miydiniz
bu Örneğin Anadolu'daki üniversitenin
diş hekimliği bölümünden mezun
olduğunuzu varsayalım ben bu diplomanızı
daha iyi bir üniversite diploması ile
yer değiştirdiğinde kendinizi başarılı
hissediyor olacak mısınız
E tabii ki de hayır kendinizce
elinizdeki bu diplomayla mezun
olduğunuzda birçok işvereniniz size
kapıların açılacağını düşünüyorsunuz
Fakat aslında durum pek de böyle değil
önemli olan hangi işi yaparsanız yapın
kendinizi geliştirmeniz inanmış olmanız
ve o yaptığınız meslekte kendinizi ne
kadar aradığınız çok önemlidir
her başarılı başlangıç noktası Hayal
etmektir Hayal etmekle başlayıp Zorlu
hedeflerimize doğru ilerlerken
yaşadığımız tecrübeler bütünüdür başarı
Hani Deniz Ya oh be İşte o yüzden tatlı
ve lezzetlidir başarı
Ben de
Zorlu hedeflerimi doğru giderken
edindiğim tecrübeler toplamı diş
hekimliği Çelik olarak karşınızdayım
komedyen olmadan ben de insanları
güldüren biliyorum Bugün televizyonda
gördüğümüz birçok ünlü ismin Gülüşleri
benim eserim ve bu in bu hiçbirisi Bana
hangi üniversiteden mezun olduğunu
sorarak gelmiyor ama merak edenleriniz
için söyleyeyim Marmara Üniversitesi
2013 diş hekimliği mezunuyum hem de
birçok insanın hayali olan iyi bir Tıp
Fakültesi'ni terk ederek girdiğimde
bölüm
hepimizin çocukluk yaşlarda yaşanmaya
başlayan hayalleri var
benim deyip Çelik olarak Elbette
çocukluk yaşta yeşermeye başlayan
hayallerim vardı bu hayallerimin
oluşmasında çevresel Ailesel Hatta
doğdun toprakların etkisi vardı çevresel
dış etkenler başarı olarak gördükleri
kriterleri hem Hayal dünyanıza hemde
yaşam tarzınıza empoze etmeye çalışırlar
benim deyip Çelik olarak farkım Tüm bu
dış etkenlerden sıyrılarak kendi
hedeflerim doğrultusunda Ne istediğimi
bilerek kararlılıkla hareket etmem dedi
Tüm bu statik olanı reddetmiştir Çünkü
in bu doğruların ve hayallerim vardı
küçük yaşlardan beri ailem çevrem ve
Arkadaşları tarafından Hayalperest
olduğum için alay konusu olabiliyordu
Örneğin sanata karşı ilgim vardı ve
resim yapıyordum derlerdi ki bu çocuk da
da ressam olacak diye dalga geçerlerdi
disease kendinize inanmazsanız bir
başkasının size inanmasını beklemeyin
Öncelikle Siz kendinize inanacak ve
hayallerinize saygı duyacaksınız Biz
hayallerinizi Tıpkı Mustafa Kemal'in
Samsun'a çıkarken
Geldikleri gibi giderler ya da Fatih
Sultan Mehmet'in İstanbul'u fethederken
ya ben bu şehri alırım ya bu beni şehir
alır kadar inanacaksınız gerçekten
inanmış ve kendini adamış insanın
elinden Kurtuluş yoktur ve kendinizi
Öncelikle sormanız gereken bir takım
sorular var bu hayaller ne kadar sizin
hayalleriniz ve bu hayallerinize ne
kadar tuttu besliyorsunuz
ve bu hayalleriniz için yapacağınız
fedakârlıkları hazırmısınız hayır demeye
Hazır mısınız
size peşinen söyleyeyim hiç bir kolaylık
hedeflerinize Giderken size Gümüş
tepside sunmayacak ben bu zorlukları
dönüm noktası olarak görüyorum Acaba bir
sonraki aşama için hazır mıyım diye
Tıpkı asma köprüden karşıya geçmek gibi
Örneğin hedefler hedefleri doğuruyor
asma köprünün karşı tarafına
bakıyorsunuz ve büyüleniyor sunuz ve
daha sonra köprünün karşısına
geçtiğinizde yeni bir köprü oluşuyor
hayallerimiz ve hedeflerimiz de tıpkı
asma köprüleri geçmek gibi
ya
Ben çocukken İstanbul'a geldiğinde ilk
hayalim Aslında bu şehirde oluşmaya
başladı ilk şehre geldiğinde manzarayı
gördüğünde büyülenmiş Tim ve ileride
Yaşamak istediğim şehri bu şehir olması
gerektiğine karar vermiştim ve
Hayallerim Bu doğrultuda şekillenmeye
başladı ailemle seyahat ederken Her
Çocuk gibi spor arabaları görmüştüm ve
bir Ferrari sorun önünden geçiyorduk ve
bir spor arabayla resim çekilmek
istemiştim içeri girmek istedik fakat
Küçük yaşlarda olmama rağmen güvenlik
görevlisi içeri almadı ve bu yaşlarda
Çok zoruma gitmişti Ve o an dedim ki
içinden
ileride geleceğim ve buradan bir araç
alacağım ve sizde göreceksiniz dedim
çünkü çocuk yaşlarda olmama rağmen Bu
benim için bir başarısızlık duygusu uydu
ve ben onu Bak bir şekilde başarılı bir
duyguya çevirmem gerekiyordu ve bu hayal
Sen beni yolculuğum bütün hayatım
boyunca yapacağım Yolculuk esnasında
besleyen hayallerden bir tanesi oldu
lise sınavlarına hazırlanırken
Üniversite sınavlarına hazırlanırken
üniversitede vizeleri ve finalleri
hazırladık hep pes etmek istediğim
zamanlar Elbette oldu hepiniz gibi ama
dedim ki
oğlum daha çok çalışmam lazım gidip
oradan aracı araba alacaksın ve Ne oldu
dersiniz iki yıl önce gittim ve o
showroomdan bu Ferrari aldım O anki
duygularımın gerçekten tarifi yok yani
bunu size ne kadar anlatabilirim
bilmiyorum ama şu şöyle söyleyeyim size
aracı aldığım için sevmiyordum Aslında
onlarca yıldır beni Zor zamanlarında
destekleyen ve kurmuş olduğu
hayallerimin gerçekleşmesi başarma
duygusu bu duygunun gerçekten dünyada
tarifi olamaz
Fethi ardından Çok geçmeden zaten 9 ay
sonra o aracı çok Benim Tarzım o araç
oğlu olduğunu anlayıp sattık liselere
giriş sınavında iyi bir puan aldım ve
iki tarafından fen lisesinde Adana Fen
Lisesi yazılmaya karar verildi meşe
öğretmenlerime göre çevreme görevi
aileme göre Fen Lisesi'ne gitmek ilerisi
için iyi bir adım dışı Fen Lisesi Bugün
Türkiye'de Fen Lisesi Dediğiniz zaman
iyi bir üniversite iyi bir meslek iyi
bir kazanç anlamına gelir ilerisi için
Fakat benim için pek de böyle değildi
çünkü ben çocukluk yaşlardan itibaren ne
yaparsam yapayım hangi işi yaparsam
yapayım ilerde yapacağım işi Global
anlamda satmak istiyorum Dur hedefim hep
ve bu Hedef doğrultusunda iyi bir
İngilizcenin hem günümüzde hem de
gelecekte iletişim aracı olduğunu
düşünmekteyim ve bu yüzden de iyi bir
İngilizce eğitim alabileceğimi lisede
okumak benim için çok önemliydi daha
sonra ailenle Gaziantep'ten Adana'ya
doğru yola çıktık
bu
yol esnasında Hiç İçime Sinmiyor Yani bu
bu çünkü benim doğru değildir Benim
istediğim bir lise değildi ve ailemle
yaptığım araçtaki konuşma sonrasında
onları vazgeçirme Osmaniye'den geri
Gaziantep'e döndük ve Gaziantep kolej
Vakfında kayıt yaptırdık ve ve lise
eğitimimi orada burslu olarak tamamladım
şık daha sonra yine o üniversite
sınavında meşhur aile baskısı ile
Gülhane Askeri Tıp Akademisi'ne
yazılmaya karar verildim Çünkü Türkiye
ülkemizde aileler çok bizlere bırakmıyor
bu kararlarımızı şıfa kat çocukluk
yaşlardan itibaren sanata karşı ilgi ve
merakım olduğu için ben hep diyordum ki
yani ileride yapmak istediğim işte
mutlaka içersin Sanatlı üretkenlik
olması gerekiyor Ayrıca ülkemizde ÖSS
dediğimiz sınav yüzünden birçoğumuz
istediği bölümlere yerleşen diyoruz ne
kadar istediğimizi çok önemli oluyor
önemli Onu al Ben ona göre
yerleştiriyoruz bu sınav sonucunda çok
daha açıkçası isteklerimiz göz önünde
bulundurma O yüzden benim için başarıya
ölçen bir sınav değil açıkçası ve Daha
sonrasında Baba ailen de doktor olmamı
istiyordu babamla Gülhane Askeri Tıp
Akademisi'ne doğru yola çıktık Ankara'ya
kayıt olmaya aile Mutluluktan uçuyordu
çevreyi baksanız o doktor olacaksınız
bana sorarsanız hiç mutlu değilim çünkü
şu sorguladım ya bu benim mesleğim
olacak Bu benim hayatım olacak bundan
sonrası için Acaba gerçekten bunu
hazırlayın ve gerçekten bu fedakarlığı
yapmaya hazır mıyım ailemi mutluluğum
yoksa benim mutluluğumu
babamla kayıt olmaya gittiğimizde okula
okulun bahçesi şunu düşündüm artık dedim
Bu benim hayatım olacak
o ve ben bu işi yapmaya hazır değilim
daha sonra Gülhane Askeri Tıp Akademisi
var ayrılarak Marmara Üniversitesi Diş
Hekimliği kayıt yaptırdım babam ben de
aylarca konuşmadı bıç ünkü Onun için çok
iyi bir bölümü terk edip bir şekilde ki
ölüme geçmiştim Fakat bu benim doğrum da
inandığım doğruları da
var
bugün yaptığım işte de aynı şekilde
üniversitenin son sınıflarına geldiğin
geldiğimizde ailem yine başladı dediler
ki işte Eyüp senin çevren Gaziantep'te
sen İstanbul'dan mezun olduğum bu işi
yapmak için senin Gaziantep'e gelmen
gerekiyor çok İstanbul'da kimse seni
tanımıyor ben de hedeflerimi bunları
bildiğim için ona göre planlamıştım Ve
şuan hayalet Nişantaşı'nda klinik
açmakta ve şuan Nişantaşı'nda kendi
Kliniği'nde hizmet veriyorum bu çevrende
benimle alay eden dalga geçen kuzenlerim
için hep bir başarıyla olayım şu anda
Neden biliyor musunuz Çünkü onların
dalga geçti alay etti Hayallerim hepsini
gerçekleştirdim ve gerçekleştirmeye de
devam ediyorum bir şeyin en iyisi yoktur
en iyisini yapabilen insanlar vardır Ben
de iyi bir Hekim olabilmek için
çabaladım ve çabalamaya devam ediyorum
Sizler zaten bir işin en iyisini yapmaya
çabaladıkça birtakım insanlar için önem
arz edersiniz ve peşinizden gelir bu ve
birçok insan için önemi ağrıdan şan
şöhret para Siz zaten İstemezseniz de
ardından gelecektir tekil bir başarı
yoktur
yüzlerce insan bir araya gelir Tıpkı
platformda bir araya geldiğimiz gibi
Sizlerde muhteşem hayalleri olan inan
bu ve kendinize güvenen insanlarsınız ve
başarılı olacaksınız
nereden biliyorum biliyor musunuz
bu çünkü burada Siz Konuşma yaparken
dinleyici olarak size kendimi görüyorum
Siz benden Ben de sizden ilham alıyorum
hayallerinize sıkıyı tutunun onları
besleyin aksi olanlara Hayır diyebilir
Çünkü başarı bazen En sevdiğiniz bile
olsa Hayır diyebilmektir tekrardan
söyleyeceğim gibi
inandığınız hayallerinizle coğrafyamızı
belirlemek sizin elinizde harekete geçin